wenn alles so gut wie viele leute das
spiel tom im urlaub das ist ein
unfassbarer blockbuster unter allen ego
shootern wenn ihr es schwer haben wollt
dann drückt die große ehre wenn ihr es
leicht haben wollt dann drückt die
kleine erdbeben wir nehmen natürlich die
große erdbeere helft den bienen damit
sie gemeinsam urlaub machen können viel
spaß beim spielen
okay wir müssen jetzt die bienen hier
ich darf die nicht mal gegen die wolken
ziehen sind die behindert achtung
freundin biene nummer eins findet ihr
zuhause sondern eher die nummer zwei die
hat nämlich diesen fächer das heißt sie
muss definitiv auf die seite hier mit
dem fächer unternehmen wir die hier mit
der aller coolen sonnenbrille und die
wir direkt hier also alles klar eine
biene die wolke berührt und alle drei
sind wieder woanders ihr wollt ihr mich
verarschen wie lange für die zeit
gebraucht um an gott freundin diese
anspannung
egal ob das das ganze spiel war ok
misterfresh dann drücke ich mal auf dich
drauf wir nehmen das diesmal ein leicht
und jetzt den bienen damit sie gemeinsam
urlaub machen können das ist nicht euer
ernst oder alter freunde ihr habt mir
das in den kommentaren empfohlen und ich
dachte das wäre echt so ein spiel wie
ernie und bert das ist ein bisschen
umfangreicher dieses spiel ist einfach
nur bienen drüberziehen
erdbeermarmeladenbrot wenn ihr noch mal
spielen
nein ich bin nicht mal spiele scheiße
tom und das erdbeermarmeladenbrot mit
honig ist eine deutsche trickfilm serie
aus dem jahr 2005 die serie wurde von
dem animationsfilm andreas führte
andreas bitte macht dann auch ein
vernünftiges spiel dafür
hh wir haben hier noch mehr spiele dann
nehmen wir mal tom und die bienen kühl
das ist ein film oder soja das ist ein
film freundlich ab neue spiel das heißt
wenn ihr es schwer haben wollt dann du
das kennen wir schon herr kollege
die libdems gelingt ok ich musste mit
denen mit den pfeiltasten rauf und
runter bewegen damit wir den kompletten
nektar hier mitnehmen dies ist definitiv
wieder ein sehr tolles spiel beim
service game dead rising namen lava aus
dem game
vielen dank
wenn ihr noch mal spielen sie sind die
ganzen spiele so behindert kurz und
scheiße
nur hängt an einer schule dem er sich
doch nicht wissen ist dass der ernst von
dieser scheiß website als ob das für
freunde ich habe dieses spiel weil ihres
mini kommentare geschrieben hat und ich
dachte es wäre so ähnlich wie ehrenwert
aber es ist einfach kompletter bullshit
ein neues spiel tom und die erdwärme aus
meinen freunden während sie zu klein um
sie zu nur milliarde zu kitschig musste
erdbeeren gießen
das ist einfach wieder ein mega
anspruchsvolles spiel halte ich musste
er abwehren so lange füttern bis sie
einfach komplett riesig sind klick
kannst du mal deine schnauze halten
was ist denn wenn ich sie hier noch mehr
hier drei sind fertig soll kommen jetzt
mal mit den nächsten jahr und der sicher
hast du deine bei marmeladen boden mit
hoher nicht du kleiner turm endlich mal
was was ich kann
ich bin halt s maul du scheiße aus ok
ich darf an fange ich erst mal diese
karte hier jetzt muss der etwas setzen
was entweder mit dem bilde damit der
frau übereinstimmte jetzt nämlich himmel
den den kopf weil der mit dem koch und
jetzt das dann hat er das und jetzt mach
ich das hier und jetzt legt er die karte
und ich blicke jetzt diese karte und
jetzt legt er wahrscheinlich genau die
karte dann lege ich die karte jetzt legt
er die und ich habe gewonnen
dieses spiels unfassbar tomtom bei
seiner mama die haben irgendwie von
jedem scheißen spiel okay ich muss
irgendwie die freunde von toms mama
ablenken
damit toms mama wasser aus dem brunnen
holen kann was passiert wenn ich jetzt
diesen fettsack hier einfach mal dahin
laufen lassen
ihr müsst die freunde rechtzeitig
anklicken damit die mama in ruhe kumpeln
und nein freunde ich drücke jetzt nicht
auf den frosch druck jetzt leider
weiterhin traurig ich kann mich nicht
mehr für diese spiele hier faszinieren
wenn ihr eventuell auch spiele kennt die
so ähnlich sind oder sowie ernie und
bert was ich mal gespielt hat dann
schreit mich und in die kommentare
solche kinder spiele spiele ich
irgendwie mega gerne und das macht noch
spaß zusammen zu schneiden allerdings
diese tom reihe ist einfach nur wenn es
eine kartoffel wäre wäre es eine
verstümmelte kartoffel wenn es trotzdem
gefallen hat will ich mich über einen
daumen hoch freuen und wir sehen im
nächsten video wieder da